hello I am Patricia bright and I am the
cover star of the spring/summer issue of
Glamour magazine coming out March 1st
and you're watching 10 things you didn't
know about me
the thing that no one ever told me about
being a youtube star is that I would be
judge jury and executioner it's almost
like a little bit of a enterprise where
I have to do everything and of course
that have support and amazing followers
but there is a lot more to do than I
could have ever imagined
the thing that I enjoy the most as part
of being a YouTube star it's probably
connecting and working with other people
filming in front of a camera in my
bedroom can be quite isolating but being
able to go out and connect with other
people and share ideas and talk to
brands and other influences or people
who do what I do is an amazing part
basically taught myself everything that
I know and I used YouTube to learn how
to work on YouTube there are so many
videos on how to edit yourself how to
take photos yourself how to sell
lighting yourself and these have been
invaluable in really improving my craft
what I know now that I didn't know ten
years ago was that life is long but also
sure and like the best years you can
have are probably ahead of you
when I was really really young I
couldn't wait to get older as I've got a
bit older I reminisce all the things
that I kind of did do or didn't do when
I was young but also realized that done
so much and then know that there's even
more I could keep doing I also didn't
know ten years ago that Britain would
leave the EU
the beauty product I can't live without
is probably night serum or night oil I
always do my skincare my really
important skincare at night and anything
that contains vitamin C as well one
night I'm using at the moment is from
DCL and it is a vitamin C booster which
it kind of has like a dr harold urey
consistency but it's really potent and
in the morning my face really glows
in my most private moments you'll
probably find me watching Netflix series
after next big series I get a little bit
addicted and whenever I'm having chill
out times I kind of over chill out and
I'll watch 10 episodes all at one go and
it'll be through the air but I'm like
why have I done this
when I'm in a bad mood I like to listen
to my sister she is what I call a voice
of reason if I'm having a bad day or
something's happening I pick up my phone
I talk to her and for some reason she's
always able to kind of calm me down make
me feel positive and a bit more centered
people come to me for a bit of a laugh a
bit of a laugh because I'm relatively
jovial but I think people also come to
me for that kind of hard-hitting advice
I often say things as it is and there's
some people who kind of need that kind
of kick from me and usually they
appreciate it
I shut down the haters by not giving
them any energy I focus on myself and my
own craft and my own grind and then I
let my success do the talking for me
I love being on the cover of Glamour
magazine because whose dream is it not
to be on the cover of a magazine
especially one that I've read for so
long I grew up on Glamour magazine I
didn't necessarily see people like
myself or just everyday girls to having
that opportunity there were people who I
looked up to who are on the covers of
the magazines and inside the magazines
as well and for me it's just
mind-boggling and out of this world to
be able to do that and I feel is worth
that there'll be a lot of other girls
like me normal everyday girls you're
gonna think you know maybe that could be
me which you never know it could be so
for more videos like this and if you
want to see what happened behind the
scenes of my color shoe make sure you
subscribe to the glamour UK youtube
channel